steve thomas is a caver he was also
involved in the rescue hi steve great
work well done you and the rest of the
team um tell us about it
uh well it was certainly a very long
rescue it was quite cold a lot of the
time
but we were highly motivated and
we were
honored to have rescue teams from around
the uk join us
and work with us seamlessly it was
fabulous
it was uh
i don't know how you rate them but it
was the best cave rescue i've ever been
involved in and certainly the biggest
and certainly the longest as far as i
remember so yeah it was quite something
special
what were the conditions like and given
that so many people were involved how
did you make sure that in those confined
spaces you just didn't get in each
other's way
uh this is part of the reason rescues
take so long is you have to coordinate
every movement that there are no um
footpaths or anything to follow we are
literally
uh our route is dictated by the nature
of the cave so
we
um
have to sometimes crawl sometimes
through water sometimes we have to climb
up or down
we have to negotiate boulders um
and what we can't do is have everybody
pass the stretcher because we don't walk
with it we have to usually pass pass it
along
once you get to the end of being passed
you have all the rescuers at the wrong
side and they can't get past so we have
to plan
um
each moment of being in the cave so that
there's always a team ahead as well as a
team behind and a team doing
it's it's quite quite complicated at
times but but but we've done this so
many times there's no surprises we've
we've practiced this and practiced this
and we've had plenty of other smaller
rescues um so
it's just a case of
being focused
staying with it and knowing that
how we do it works it's slow but it does
get there
and all the time there's running water
you're in a confined space and and it's
freezing cold i'm guessing
yeah caves are drafty they they're
they're not sort of warm places so once
you soak through uh
you're okay if you're moving but once
you stop and there's a lot of stopping
uh
the chill factor is quite high with the
with the the draft through the cave and
so it is easy to get cold so you need to
keep your spirits up and you know we
look after each other you know that's
kind of there's a lot of camaraderie
with doing this and uh
you know it's just
keep your spirits up remain mentally
strong and just stay focused on what
we're doing it is a minute by minute
thing um and we don't break it down
beyond what we're doing really other
than you know the team that are sort of
working ahead um
and then you know
eventually one of those moments is the
moment when we exit the cave
did you know it was always going to be a
good outcome
i think for the most part we we have to
we know what we're doing and we know
the condition of the patient
we certainly we have our team doctors
and medics
so we're aware of of of his or her
condition um
and we go in with the intention of
coming out with a successful outcome you
know that
it's it's it's you know we stay positive
stay focused
and get the job done
i think you had a bit of interaction
with the with the cave of the patient
didn't you what was his condition like
and did he manage to say anything
uh yeah it's right it's a long time for
anybody to be um strapped into a
stretcher
and immobilized especially with injuries
so um
you know you take that into account but
but
there were times when he was um
quite perky he's a very strong character
um
uh yeah he was okay he was certainly
very happy to be out of the cave we
wouldn't be
what did you say to him
actually as we came out of the cave um i
was just fortunate to be in exactly the
right position to be able to lean into
him and
say you're out of the cave now it was it
was a it was a great moment
and how did he react did he smile or was
he just so relieved
you can see the the you can see he was
happy relieved yeah
he wasn't going to get up and jump
around
for joy but yeah he was obviously
clearly happy
yeah i'm sure um so you know on a
personal level no i i cannot understand
why you get into a tiny cave full of
water that's drafty um and and then you
find that somebody falls and breaks all
sorts of bones what on earth do you do
that for
well people people just should challenge
themselves it's good to sometimes go
beyond your comfort zone and certainly
um
uh it's very rewarding to challenge
yourself whether you climb a mountain
ride a horse whatever you do i mean it's
healthy i mean statistically it's not
very dangerous
and it's very easy to be careful uh we
know we know what the dangers are
um sometimes things go wrong i mean
the the rocks that moved on saturday
hadn't moved for
how many thousands of years but that was
the day they chose to move you know but
there was plenty of other years when
they just didn't move so it's just bad
timing but most of the time things go
off without a hitch
yeah biggest risk i want to take is
falling off a bar stool drinking
martinis i think that's the biggest risk
i'm going to take and you guys are just
and girls i'm sure as well absolute
superstars thank you very much indeed
for taking the time to explain to us
what happened thanks a lot